bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver en direct sur figaro live
aujourd'hui mercredi 7 juillet 2021 doit
être rendu le jugement dans le procès
milla cette lycéenne de 18 ans victime
de harcèlement et menacé de mort pour
avoir critiqué l'islam sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui vit désormais sous
protection policière ne devrions pouvoir
vous faire vivre en direct l'annoncé de
ce jugement avant que ce jugement ne
soit rendu dans quelques minutes
maintenant nous vous proposons de
revenir sur la ferme il a et pour nous
accompagner
aujourd'hui nous avons le plaisir
d'avoir en plateau avec nous stefan
kovacs qui rend reporter au service
société du figaro bonjour stéphane jean
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur
figaro live vous avez couvert le procès
des harceleurs 2001 pour le figaro nous
avons pu lire vos nombreux papiers à ce
sujet que va-t-il concrètement se passer
à 9 heures nous attendons effectivement
le jugement concrètement qu'est ce qui
se passe donc le l'audience et s'est
déroulée le 21 et le 22 juin donc il ya
une quinzaine de jours et elle a été
mise en délibéré donc aujourd'hui à 9
heures donc le président devrait
annoncer son jugement pour les treize
prévenus donc on attend évidemment la
présence de millas de son avocat richard
malka probablement aussi peut-être on le
verra sur les images qui devraient être
nous être livrés par par l' agence afp
deux peut-être des accusés ils étaient
au nombre de 13
il devrait arriver au tribunal de paris
puisque le jugement sera rendu en direct
donc vers 9 heures au tribunal de paris
nous devrions donc voir cette arrivée de
ses protagonistes peut-être
s'enfermeront t-il en toute
confidentialité pour l'annonceur
l'annoncent qui leur sera faite à eux
d'abord avant que cette annonce ait ce
jugement soit rendu public
on espère également l'intervention
ultérieure de l'avocat de 2000 à richard
malka et peut-être même 2000 à elle même
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur cette
affaire me l'a justement avec vous
stéphane kovacs on comprenne un peu
pourquoi on en est arrivé là
elle débute comment cette affaire me l'a
alors elle débute en janvier 2000 20 mai
alors 16 ans et demi elle est en
première et
lc sur instagram qu'elle discute avec
des amis quand intervient un jeune homme
qui la drague lourdement
et donc à un moment et elle elle
s'énerve et elle lui dit qu'elle préfère
les filles
du coup le jeune homme l'insultent
commence à l'insulter et mila va faire
une vidéo où elle tient des propos qui
vont choquer certains internautes
elle s'en prend à la avec des propos
très crus et c'est ça qui va lancer la
ferme il a puisque après déferleront sur
elle des milliers d' insulte de menaces
de mort de viol d'étranglement de
tortures et autres voilà alors ça c'est
la première vidéo
la première vidéo c'était on va dire la
première partie de la sphère donc en
janvier 2020 mais elle va continuer
cette affaire-là elles valent continuer
jamais jamais les menaces ne seront même
quand mines a mis là va arrêter de
d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux
pas très longtemps elle va elle va pas
réussir à arrêter très longtemps mais
elle va quand même arrêter et finalement
en novembre deuxième vidéo ou
mais il a dit que le son doigt dans le
trou du cul della elle n'a toujours pas
retiré
et donc là une deuxième salve de menaces
de mort et de viol
s'ensuivront et nos treize prévenus
qu'ils seront jugés tout à l'heure font
partie de sa deuxième salle c'est à dire
que leurs messages ont été envoyés
mi-novembre au moment de cette deuxième
vidéo nous montre cette deuxième vidéo
donc diffusée par milla sur tik tok des
menaces de mort du harcèlement nombre
puisqu'on estime à 100 milles 1 les
messages qui ont pu lui être envoyée
ça fait partie aussi de la l'ampleur
qu'a prise cette affaire c'est ce nom
considérable de messages envoyés sur les
réseaux sociaux
ce nom considérable qui ne s'arrête
jamais j'aurais nuit qui a continué même
pendant l'audience
et
c'est pas juste
sale [ __ ] et cetera vous je peux vous
lire certains messages pour qu'on se
rende bien compte pour qu'on comprenne
exactement de quoi sont accusés
effectivement ses harceleurs donc ils
font partie des des individus qui ont
harcelé et envoyé des menaces à millas à
partir de novembre 2009 2020 pardon on
vous écoute stéphane si vous avez
quelques exemples de ce que tu oses
quelqu'un lui broie le crâne par pitié
écrit par exemple une étudiante en
anglais tu mérites de te faire égorger
salle grosse [ __ ] l'a mis là elle
continuera jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un a
trouvé la crève et c'est tout ce qu'elle
mérite
bon [ __ ] la fort qu'on en parle plus
mettez-y un coup de machette de ma part
à cette grosse [ __ ] bon et je vous en
passe on l'a il faut aussi dire le
contexte on est juste après l'assassinât
samuel patty est donc évidemment la
menace aussi d'une semelle pâtit
d'accord et donc on présume que ces
individus avaient connaissance
évidemment de ce fait divers atroce et
du contexte dans lequel le harcèlement
avait lieu en novembre 2020
on aimerait savoir un peu plus de choses
sur cette jeune femme donc il ya
aujourd'hui de 18 ans depuis le mois de
mars qui est mis là alors sa mère nous
en a dressé un portrait est là elle a
parlé de s'inquiéter de sa joie de vivre
c'est quelqu'un de très sociable qui
aime beaucoup rencontrer des gens parler
discuter
bon elle a aussi décrit
les tourments demi là enfin même avant
que toute cette histoire n'arrive milla
qui est homosexuel avait déjà connu le
harcèlement elle raconte d'ailleurs dans
son livre que se promener main dans la
main avec sa petite amie c'était pas
possible
avoir des robes des jupes trop courtes
comme elle aime c'était pas possible non
plus elle se faisait critique et
harcelés au nom de l'islam donc déjà
avant et c'est aussi ça qui explique que
les exploser au moment de la vidéo
nous sommes en direct sur figaro
l'arrivée sur le chat figaro live sur
youtube vous voyez on a les images en
direct de la fée du tribunal de paris où
devrait être rendu ce jugement
concernant le procès qui implique 13
accusés de harcèlement et de menaces de
mort à l'encontre de cette jeune
lycéenne qui a 18 ans maintenant nous
attendons ce jugement qui devrait nous
parvenir à compter de 9h on attend
également l'arrivée de millas et de son
avocat et possiblement des des treize
accusés s'ils se présentent aujourd'hui
on devrait donc les voir arriver puis
logiquement j'imagine sans fermer tous
ensemble dans la salle d'audience pour
avoir ce jugement qui devrait être
rendue et le public devrait avoir
connaissance de ce jugement et nous
mêmes et vous donc peu après 9h on garde
l'antenne jusqu'à ce jugement vous
pouvez nous poser toutes vos questions
vous pouvez nous poser vos
interrogations et nous livrer vos
commentaires en rapport avec cette
affaire milla et les accusations
auxquels sont soumis ces accusés depuis
le mois de janvier depuis le mois de
juin pardon puisque le procès a eu lieu
au mois de juin qu'il a été bien les
accusations ont été mis en délibéré et
nous attendons le jugement aujourd'hui
on est en direct avec stéphane cause
kovacs qui est grand reporter au service
société du figaro elle est là experte
pour répondre à vos questions je salue
et sur le chat youtube figaro live la
présence d'anti patick psychotique qui
nous dit bonjour bonjour à vous france
la villeneuve est également là angélique
le mat également bonjour ms myriam 1979
ne dit qu'elle soutient milla elle
ajoute également que l espère que ces
treize accusés vont être condamnés et
elle considère que ce sont des
terroristes
on parlait de millas on sait que c'est
une lycéenne une jeune femme dont l'âge
elle n'était que de 16 ans et demi au
début de la ferme c'est qu'elle aime la
musique elle aime chanter elle manie des
hlm le maquillage on connaît maintenant
son visage ses différentes coiffures son
maquillage c'est pierre singh son allure
en général qui ne passe pas inaperçu son
ambition est évidemment de s'engager
dans la musique et dans une carrière
artistique est quelque peu compromise
aujourd'hui quelque peu même je dirais
tout son avenir elle a répondu on à
venir je ne le vois pas qui va lui
alors elle a arrêté l'école à l'été
déscolarisés elle ne pouvait plus aller
bien sûr dans son lycée et elle a même
arrêté le cned
elle voulait suivre une formation de
maquillage évidemment
en distance yale c'est un peu compliqué
et de toute façon comme dit son avocat
qui va lui donner un stage qui va
l'embaucher avec ses gardes du corps
pour l'instant mais nan c'est pas ce
qu'elle va devenir donc elle est sous
protection policière les vies a priori
ses parents s'est pas éternisé en isère
donc elle les déscolarisés c'est ce que
vous avez dit donc elle vit un peu
bancarisés on va dire tout à fait tout à
fait elle ne sort pas elle explique les
rares fois où elle sort c'est avec une
perruque puisque maintenant tout le
monde connaît ses cheveux verts ou mot
fin qui qui peuvent changer enfin on
peut la reconnaître
et puis entouré de policiers comment
s'annonce son avenir après ce procès une
fois que le jugement aura été rendu que
les caméras de télévision ce seront
éteintes que ne sera plus au coeur de
cette affaire médiatique et médiatisé
que va devenir milla est ce qu elle le
sait elle même elle ne le sait pas elle
ne le sait pas et nous non plus j'espère
pour elle que elle va pouvoir un jour
trouver une voie elle est est ce qu'elle
va pouvoir aller à l'étranger comme le
pensent certains
est-ce qu'elle va réussir à se faire
oublier et avoir quand même une vie
normale pour l'instant c'est en tant
qu'assistant un gros point
d'interrogation
bonjour nicolas mais made my day il ne
faut requa sur youtube qui a une
question tout à fait pertinente et qui
vous demande stéphane est ce un procès
historique qu'a t'il d'original pour
qu'ils soient historiques le nombre
d'accusés de cyber harcèlement dans un
seul procès peut-être
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est un
procès du drame hier déjà le cas oui
parce que c'est donc une des premières
enquêtes du tout nouveau pôle national
de lutte contre la haine en ligne qui a
été créé il ya quelques mois et en plus
l'infraction de cyber harcèlement a été
créé elle-même par une loi de 2018
et parce qu'on n'en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure
c'est ces jeunes prévenus n'avaient
enfin en tout cas ont-ils dit non on
n'avait pas conscience du tout de
harceler mis là ils ont dit mais qu'est
ce que j'ai fait moi j'ai envoyé qu'un
message je suis pas un seul homme et
leurs avocats d'ailleurs on dit mais mon
client tout seul il y aurait pas eu la
ferme il a bon sauf que donc ce que dit
la loi 2018 c'est que l'infraction de
cyber harcèlement peut être constitué
dès lors que plusieurs personnes s'en
prennent à une même victime
sachant que leurs propos ou leur
comportement caractérise une répétition
et même sens que chacune de ces
personnes est agi de manière concertée
donc dans le cas qui nous intéresse ce
sont des accusés au nombre de treize qui
ont diffusé leurs menaces de mort ou
leurs menaces via les réseaux sociaux à
partir de novembre 2020 on la voit
arriver un mille ha en direct et au
tribunal de paris avec son avocat à
richard malka vont se rendre dans la
salle d'audience pour pour écouter le
jugement qui devrait être rendue
concernant les treize accusés accusés
d'avoir harcelé et menacé de mort un ses
parents qui suivent derrière
on espère stéphane kovacs à voir
évidemment l'intervention de l'avocat de
millas richard malka est probablement et
on l'espère celle de mme hill a
elle-même à la fin de deux sets
je sais pas si on peut appeler ça une
audience mais en tout cas de une fois
que le jugement aura été rendues en leur
présence et j'espère qu'ils pourront
s'exprimer et qu'on pourrait entendre ce
qu'ils ont à dire
alors on est en direct depuis le
tribunal de paris et dans les locaux du
figaro sur figaro live et sur youtube en
présence de stéphane kovacs de reporter
au service société du figaro pour
répondre à vos questions et relayer vos
commentaires concernant la ferme il a et
le procès qui a eu lieu au mois de juin
nous attendons le jugement par rapport à
ce procès qui interviendra dans quelques
minutes
on a parlé de ses treize harceleur
stefan kovacs
quel est leur profil qui sont ces
individus est ce qu'il ya des femmes
parmi eux une telle profession quel
milieu social et caractérise donc sur
ces treize prévenus il y a dix hommes
trois femmes
ils sont à peine plus âgés mais là c'est
à dire qu'ils ont entre 18 et 29 ans
pour la plupart étudiants vivent chez
leurs parents
la plupart aussi n'ont pas fait beaucoup
d'études ont arrêté même avant le bac
mais certains sont d'études sont
étudiants malgré tout oui certains sont
étudiants en psycho par exemple en
humanité endroit et pourtant et pourtant
ils ont écrit des horreurs ils ont écrit
des horreurs et pourtant ils s'en
défendent
quelle a été leur leur ligne de défense
on va dire qu'on t-il plaidé pour leur
défense pour justifier leurs actes et
bien la bêtise tout simplement la bêtise
l'ignorance de la loi bien sûr
les maturités à j'ai pas réfléchi à je
savais pas je me suis pas rendu compte
mais mais là la même pas lu mon message
voilà est-ce que le procureur a expliqué
c'est que peu importe qu'il y ait pas
d'arobase de hashtag 2
d'adressent me l'a directement tous ces
messages sont nés menaces de mort et
mila
est censé les avoir lus d'ailleurs elle
les a lus sa mère nous racontait que
tous les soirs toutes les nuits elle
vérifie tous les messages qui parle de
millas et elle transmet ce qu'ils sont
de l'asb écran construire l'écran aux
enquêteurs parce que justement on
parlait de ce procès historique mais
c'est le premier peut-être d'une série
puisque comme on le disait tout à
l'heure il ya eu 100 mille messages et
et c'est difficile d'interpeller de
trouver les auteurs le président nous a
dit que il n'ya 43
individus qui ont été identifiées
auteurs de menaces
pourquoi on en a eu que 13 parce que sur
ces 43
certains habitent à l'étranger et puis
d'autres sont mineurs et les mineurs
seront jugés un peu plus tard mais dans
leur région je rebondis par rapport à ce
que vous dites stefan kovacs sur le
commentaire de django liquide sur
youtube le chat du figaro live sur
youtube
treize jugé pour cent mille menaces de
mort le conti n'y ait pas effectivement
certains c'est pour ça que j'ai expliqué
qu'il y aura d'autres
d'autres procès comme celui là le
procureur nous a bien dit que l' enquête
continuer et qu' il y aurait peut-être
régulièrement enfin espérons qu'un jour
ça s'arrête
mais il y aurait donc d'autres procès
avec d'autres prévenus nicolas my days
inn fort qu'à de nouveaux merci à lui
pour pour son commentaire il pose une
question les treize accusés ont-ils un
point commun sur leurs croyances
religieuses ou pas du tout de mon style
alors la plupart sont athées il y à des
musulmans aussi et même des chrétiens
le point commun je dirais c'est qu'ils
ont tous et peut-être un proche un
membre de leur famille qui s'est
converti à l'islam ou leur meilleur ami
musulman
en tout cas ils ont été choqués même
s'ils ne sont pas musulmans eux mêmes
par ce qu'ils considèrent comme des
attaques contre les musulmans
eliane b toujours sur le chat youtube de
figaro live new deal insulte à une
théorie n'est pas comparable à l'insulté
à une personne
ça nous permet de vous poser la question
que reproche-t-on concrètement aux
harceleurs de millas en quoi
aujourd'hui on peut considérer que ce
procès a voulu mettre en avant la
gravité de leurs faits et gestes
en tout cas de leurs propos que leur est
il reproché concrètement j'ai d'avoir
menacé de mort enfin pour certains
d'autres de viol milla s'est c'est c'est
une infraction donc voilà et comme je
disais tout à l'heure
se rajoute le harcèlement mais le
harcèlement depuis 2018
même s'il ne n'avais pas conscience de
harceler même s'ils ont fait qu envoyer
un message
ils font partie de la meute et et et
donc ils ont harcelé 1000 1 que
risque-t-il concrètement quelle peine à
quelque peu ville peuvent-ils être
condamné aujourd'hui donc le procureur a
requis jusqu'à six mois de prison avec
sursis pour ceux qui avaient menacé de
mort et
il y en a un
pour lequel il a requis la relaxe au
bénéfice du doute
ce jeune homme avait écrit me là il faut
la faire sauter n'ont pas pardon faut la
faire sauter juste et avec une photo de
millas et il a expliqué à l'audience que
en fait il y parlait du compte twitter
de millas qu'il voulait faire sauter du
coup on a eu une discussion sur est-ce
qu'on est ce que ce terme faire sauter
s'emploie sur twitter et me l'a elle
même en a convenu
elle a dit que effectivement on pouvait
qu on croire qu'il a voulu faire sauter
son compte et concernant milla parce que
beaucoup s'interrogent sur sa
responsabilité à l est ce que d'une
façon ou d'une autre à un moment donné
en particulier au début de la faire elle
a pu être accusé d'avoir elle même tenu
des propos qui auraient pu rentrer dans
le code de la loi et dans ce qui lui
permet de dire la loi
qu'en est il par rapport à elle alors je
suis la réalisation ou une possible
condamnation pas dire donc justement
d'abord il ya d'ailleurs il ya eu une
enquête milla n'a rien à se reprocher
elle a juste blasphémer on a le droit en
france de critiquer une religion et
c'est ce qu'elle a fait c'est tout ajout
des mots très crus certes avec des mots
très crus ça donc en fait il ya une
distinction qui est établi entre la
critique qu'on peut faire d'une religion
et les insultes envers une religion qui
sont donc autorisées en france en tout
cas qui ne sont pas illégales en
revanche si elle s'était permis
d'insulter les musulmans
là c'était différent et oui mais dont
elle n'a pas fait est là juste là fait
mais nous sommes en direct sur figaro
live vous pouvez suivre avec nous et
stefan kovacs grand reporter au service
société du figaro
le jugement dans la ferme il a ou en
tout cas le jugement de treize prévenus
qui sont donc accusés d'avoir harcelé
milla à partir de novembre 2020 sur les
réseaux sociaux après une publication de
cette jeune femme sur tik tok
ces prévenus sont attendus aussi au
tribunal de paris dont on voit en ce
moment les images en direct nous avons
vu il y à quelques minutes l'arrivée de
millas en compagnie de son avocat
richard malka et des membres de son
entourage dont ses parents
on ne sait pas encore si les treize
prévenus seront présents pour écouter ce
jugement qui doit être rendu dans
quelques minutes maintenant puisqu'il
est attendu à hanover on vient de le
voir c'est c'est treize prévenus
stéphane vous disiez risquent des peines
de prison avec sursis pardon pas de
peine de prison ferme et on peut
peut-être parler de deux autres hommes
qui ont été jugés et qui ont eu eux de
la prison ferme en tout cas l'un d'entre
eux
donc ça
d'abord il ya eu en août c'est qu'ils
n'ont rien à voir avec ce procès qui
n'ont accès wi juste pour dire que dans
la ferme il a il ya déjà eu deux
condamnations
d'abord en août un jeune homme algérien
qui vit en france qui a reconnu milla
lors d'un séjour linguistique à malte
il la menace est violent et il est allé
la retrouver à son hôtel et ce jeune
homme a été condamné à malte à de la
prison avec sursis et puis en octobre un
homme de 23 ans qui a été condamné lui
alors à de la prison ferme trois ans de
prison dont un an et demi ferme
d'ailleurs c'est le double de ce que
demandait le parquet et lui il avait
mimé un égorgement
c'est un jeune homme qui est sous
curatelle renforcée mais qui me qui n'a
pas de troubles psychiatriques d'accord
là donc ça ces deux condamnations à de
la prison ferme pour des individus pas
le premier à ne pas le jeune algérien
pardon mais qu'ils ont et les jeux qui
sont allés sur six avec sursis mais ce
sont des condamnations parallèle à aux
condamnations dont on attend le jugement
aujourd'hui
vous voyez derrière nous et les images
du tribunal de paris où se sont
présentés milla et son avocat richard
malka on a vu passer quelques jeunes
également qu'ils sont peut-être des
jeunes parmi les prévenus qui donc ils
sont au nombre de 13 et dont on attend
le jugement aujourd'hui ce jugement qui
devrait tomber d'ici 9 heures en tout
cas qui est attendu pour 9 heures je
salue sur les réseaux sociaux et du
figaro valent pas eu 34 bonjour on va
pas eu qui commentent sur lefigaro.fr
figaro live un certain nombre de
réflexions qui qui sont les siennes pour
millas je trouve que les médias en font
trop et qu'elle est trop devant les
écrans elle a joué la provocation et la
jeunesse actuelle répond sans réaliser
les idioties
il a voulu faire le buzz elle a réussi
les parents dès le départ aurait dû
l'arrêter
c'est vrai qu'on peut estimer qu'il ya
une forme d'ambiguïté dans le
comportement de cette jeune femme qui ne
quitte pas effectivement le support en
l'occurrence les réseaux sociaux tik tok
instagram sur lesquels sont nés les les
insultes et les menaces de mort et qui
d'une certaine façon
entretien on peut le lui reprocher ce ce
climat là c'est difficile pour une jeune
femme de son âge de quitter totalement
les réseaux sociaux pour une jeune femme
qui a sa personnalité puisque justement
on l'a vu tout à l'heure
elle aime rencontrer des gens parler et
alors elle veut devenir maquilleuse donc
elle montre ce qu'elle sait faire l on
al se maquiller elle montre ces photos
elle dessine aussi très bien dans quelle
montre ses dessins et puis qu'est ce que
vous voulez les toute seule enfermée
chez elle
si en plus on lui ferme cette ouverture
sur les voiles ailleurs on définit très
exactement exactement dont elle
s'efforce de ne parlait plus que de
maquillage ou deux
musique mais effectivement quand
quelquefois elle est un peu poussée à
bout et bien réagit elle réagit et c'est
humain vous aviez une anecdote je crois
stefan kovacs contairement juste
concernant justement cette privation de
liberté donc qu'ils aient subi en ce
moment par la jeune mis là vous aviez ce
cette anecdote sur un chien elle aurait
souhaité avoir un chien il ya quelques
temps et ça lui a été refusé mais oui
parce qu'un chien il faut le sortir tout
simplement il faut le faire promener et
le simple fait de sortir la maison
danger c'est ça ou alors il faudrait
qu'elle se promène entouré de policiers
voilà et maître malka aussi lancé au
prévenu vous après l'audience vous
pourrez aller boire un verre pour
décompresser
mais là elle pourra même pas elle peut
même pas aller boire un verre elle
retournera chez elle en tout cas dans un
lieu où elle sera protégée et
par cette protection policière en tout
cas qui est en ce moment autour d'elle
dans son quotidien
je crois que sur les images que l'on
voit en ce moment du renvoi l'avocat
franco qui est l'un des avocats de
jordan le jardin des prêtresses prévenu
qui est attendu aujourd'hui ou en tout
cas pour lequel on attend le jugement
sur cette affaire
voilà jordan qui est un cuisinier donc
ça c'est le sait le plus âgé il a 29 ans
il est cuisinier dans le calvados et il
a écrit ouais je suis sûr que si je mets
un coup de bitam il à l arrêtera de
faire chier le monde cette mal baisées
et vous qui avez assisté au procès par
exemple quel effet quel quel individu
était ce jordan comment s'est il
comporté par exemple pendant son procès
avec ce que vous avez senti qu'il avait
pris conscience par exemple de la deûle
à la gravité des faits qui lui sont
reprochés
pas vraiment même si la barre monnaie je
m'excuse en regardant ses chaussures
mais lui donc lui il a reproché à cette
enquête d'être une supercherie
il a même dit que l'audience était un
spectacle
il a raconté que six gendarmes étaient
venus le chercher à l'aube dans son
petit village voilà il s'est un peu
moqué de cette trouve excessif on veut
résumer sa pensée
le oui l'ampleur de ce qui lui arrive
oui et puis l'intérêt que porte la
justice et les médias sur son compte en
garde à vue il a réitéré ses propos
c'est à dire que ça lui ferait du bien
mis là effectivement on n'ira pas plus
loin notamment je vous remercie de me
suivre en direct sur le chat du figaro
figaro live et sur youtube vous êtes un
certain nombre maintenant a commenté un
set cette affaire et ce jugement que
nous attendons au raf là
excusez moi oui c'est aux rafles ah
pardon nous dit j'ai toujours su que les
réseaux sociaux était un réel danger il
en a développé des histoires similaires
- entendu une question quelles sont les
responsabilités de ces réseaux sociaux
effectivement vous êtes un certain
nombre à vous demander pour quelles
raisons ni twitter ni instagram ni ni
tik tok ne sont condamnés ou en tout cas
mis en cause dans cette affaire
augusta nous dit à propos de harcèlement
c'est grave
moi j'ai été victime de harcèlement
pendant quatre ans et je sais que ce
n'est pas une vie il faut en parler il
faut que ça se sache
j'ai elle ajoute j'ai
j'espère qu'elle va gagner son procès je
la soutiens je sais que ce que c'est que
le harcèlement
bon courage eliane bay eliane bennoo dit
oui à propos de ce qu'on disait sur 1000
acquis à qui certains peuvent reprocher
d'être encore en lien on va dire avec
les réseaux sociaux et de publier de
temps en temps quelques messages
qu'at-elle d'autre que les réseaux
sociaux demande
eliane b effectivement nicolas maiden
fort qu'à nous dit milla n'a rien fait
d'illégal mais twitter avait suspendu
son compte twitter à ses règles peu
importe la loi ne faudrait-il pas un
procès twitter est ce qu'il est question
à stefan kovacs qui d'une façon ou d'une
autre les réseaux sociaux soit mis en
cause dans cette affaire par exemple
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'ont souligné
plusieurs des avocats des prévenus
je me souviens que que l'un le conseil
des oiseaux avait dit mais on comprend
pas comment a procédé l'accusation on
voit devant nous un panachage savamment
dosé avec dix hommes trois femmes des
athées des musulmans des catholiques
venus des quatre coins de france et
pourquoi il n'ya pas ici de
représentants de twitter ou de tik tok
pourquoi ne pas un crime
incriminer les plateformes parce que ce
sont eux qui ont volé la vie 2001 je
découvre au fur et à mesure de ce direct
vos messages que vous diffusée en ce
moment sur les tchats du figaro
valent pas eu 34 qui est
poste de nombreux commentaires depuis le
début de ce direct sur lefigaro.fr
figaro live répond en ce moment à
d'autres internautes en défendant son
opinion qui est de dire qu'elle n'aurait
jamais accepté ce comportement de sa
fille
c'est une question d'éducation dit elle
nous sommes toujours en direct et vous
le voyez les images de ce tribunal de
paris dans lesquels dans lequel s'est
s'est engouffré on va dire assez
rapidement d'ailleurs mis là ils sont un
avocat richard malka
ainsi que quelques jeunes dont on pense
qu'ils sont effectivement parmi les
treize prévenus on en voit un jeune
garçon arrivé là en ce moment et qui
devrait rentrer dans cette salle où sera
rendu le jugement dans quelques minutes
on a vu l'avocat ron branco qui l'a qui
est l'avocat d'un des treize prévenus
pour lesquels stéphane kovacs nous a
précisé qu'il s'agissait d'un garçon qui
s'appelle jordan qui a probablement été
l'un des plus virulents sur les réseaux
sociaux dans ces menaces de mort et
d'enseignement c'est dans ces matches
des insultes et dans ces insultes on va
dire à caractère sexuel c'est un
jugement qui se fait attendre
il est prononcé par le président du
tribunal ce jugement avec c'est en
présence des avocats et des prévenus et
de mila et son avocat qu'est ce qui vous
a le plus frappé lors des audiences de
ce procès au mois de juin
je dirais l'immaturité
des prévenus on a vu qu'ils étaient tous
très jeunes et
mais quand même alors il faut rappeler
aussi le contexte on est en plein
confinement en novembre ces jeunes qui
sont étudiants n'ont pas de cours sont
peut-être seuls dans leur chambre face à
l'ordinateur d'ailleurs c'est ce que
certains ont expliqué par exemple
nilesat à nice atta qui est étudiante en
psychologie qui
donc avait eu que quelques heures de
cours en novembre et
et ce soir-là 2h34 du matin elle se dit
qu'elle va envoyer un mail à millas un
mail dont l'objet est commandes de
dessins qui commande donc puisque comme
je vous le disais mais il a dessiné et
propose quelques fois ses dessins donc
elle écrit commandes de dessin elle
commence très gentiment à la féliciter
sur ses qualités
et puis et puis ça dérive
elle a raconté à l'audience qu'elle elle
s'était sentie a été très choquée des
propos de millas étant musulmane et est
là elle a écrit un ps donc de son mail
va bien te faire fourrer sombre [ __ ] je
te souhaite de mourir de la façon la
plus atroce qui puisse exister
et si jamais ça tarde je m'en chargerai
moi même je me ferai un plaisir de la
serre et ton corps avec mon plus beau
couteaux et des les laisser pourrir ton
corps dans un bois et ça finit par un
smiley souriant
tout ça ce sont les propos tenus par une
jeune femme étudiante en psycho
l'étudiante en psychologie un
comportement avec cette jeune femme
durant durant les audiences au procès on
peut pas enfin disons qu'elle n'était ni
arrogante nie complètement
désolé
elle
n'a pas présenté ses excuses à millas je
vous rappelle qu'il ya un seul prévenu
le premier réseau qui a demandé au
président s'il pouvait présenter enfin
il a dit je voudrais m'excuser et le
président le président a dit très bien
mais alors on dit pas je m'excuse
on se tourne vers 1000 à et dit je te
présente mes excuses et la personne peut
accepter ou refuser et donc c'est ce
qu'il a fait il s'est tourné vers 1000 à
et lui a présenté ses excuses et il lui
a dit j'espère que tu retrouveras une
vie normale bientôt c'est le seul parmi
les c'est le salaire je pensais que
justement laisse les autres après les
forcément faire la même chose et bien
non nous sommes en direct sur figaro
live sur le tchat
youtube de figaro et vous le voyez ces
images en direct depuis le tribunal de
paris on attend le jugement
concernant la ferme il a et les treize
prévenus qu'ils doivent aujourd'hui
avoir connaissance de ce jugement et qui
sont accusés d'avoir harcelé sur les
réseaux sociaux et proféré des menaces
de mort pour certains à l'encontre de
cette jeune lycéenne qui a aujourd'hui
18 ans du nom de millas et qui je vous
le rappelle avait été harcelés pour
avoir critiqué l'islam une première fois
en janvier 2020 il est sur instagram et
puis de nouveau en novembre 2020 sur tik
tok les treize prévenus aujourd'hui qui
se présente au tribunal pour écoute pour
entendre le jugement sont accusés
d'avoir proféré des menaces de mort ou
des attaques en novembre 2020 donc lors
de d'une publication
une deuxième publication de la jeune
femme sur les réseaux sociaux
évidemment vous êtes un certain nombre
sur les réseaux sociaux je vous en
remercie a commenté un cette affaire est
à vous poser quelques questions muscade
ou muscade s'interroge quid des autres
harceleur tous ceux qui n'ont pas été
poursuivis effectivement vous vous
interrogez il ya cent mille plus de
100000 menaces qui ont été proférées sur
les réseaux sociaux et seulement 13
prévenus qui attendent leur jugement
aujourd'hui et qui ont été confrontés à
un prof un procès
cette différence on explique comment
stéphane coppey comme je disais tout à
l'heure en fait il ya eu 43 qui ont été
identifiés
et parce que c'est difficile
d'identifier un et donc sur ces 43
certains vivent à l'étranger et d'autres
sont mineurs seront jugés donc plus tard
dans leur département on va vous
retrouver dans quelques instants
pour suivre en direct le jugement
concernant cette affaire nous sommes en
direct sur fuyards alive nous attendons
comme vous ce jugement que nous vous
nous devrions pouvoir vous faire vivre
au moment où il va être rendue je vous
propose qu'on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour continuer ce direct a tout
de suite
si vous nous rejoignez à l'instant sur
figaro live nous sommes en direct pour
évoquer et vivre avec vous le jugement
qui devrait être rendu dans quelques
minutes sur la ferme il a treize
prévenus sont aujourd'hui au tribunal de
paris en tout cas représentés par leurs
avocats
en présence de millas et de son avocat
elle ils attendent ce jugement qui doit
être rendu ils sont accusés d'avoir
proféré des menaces de mort entre autres
sur les réseaux sociaux à partir de
novembre 2020 suite à des publications
de 1000 à 2000 assure sur tik tok
je suis avec stefan kovacs grand
reporter au service société du figaro et
vous êtes très nombreux à commenter et
poser vos questions sur les tchats du
figaro sur figaro.fr et sur youtube
beaucoup d'entre vous vous demande quel
est le profil de ces treize prévenus qui
sont ils on peut peut-être revenir
dessus stefanko boxe comme l'a dit l'un
des avocats des prévenus nous avons un
savon panachage de jeunes venus de
quatre coins de la france des 10 hommes
trois femmes des athées des musulmans
des catholiques des étudiants voilà il
disait ça pour se moquer un petit peu en
disant sur les cent mille messages vous
avez trouvé c'est très joli et pourquoi
c'est très justement on dirait qu'ils
sont panaché bon alors on expliquait que
il y aura d'autres procès comme celui là
parce que l' enquête se poursuit que
aussi les messages malheureusement
malveillants se poursuivre aussi et et
d'autres prévenus seront d'autres
personnes seront jugées dans les mois et
les mois qui viennent qui arrive
voilà nous avions il ya quelques minutes
les images en direct depuis le tribunal
de paris ou en ce moment est rendu le
jugement à huis clos devant et les
principaux protagonistes de cette
affaire
je me permets de citer quelques tweets
de notre consoeur aurélie sarrot qui est
journaliste pour lci et qui se trouve
dans la salle d'audience et qui a vécu
comme nous l'arrivée de 2000 a
accompagné de ses parents et de son
avocat de son avocat maître malka et qui
disait à 8h53 que la salle était pleine
ils attendaient à ce moment là les
prévenus elle précise que milla était
comme à chaque fois entouré par par un
service de protection effectivement mis
là depuis le début de cette affaire
bénéficie d'une protection policière
aurélie sarrot je ne sais pas si j'ai
cité donc notre consoeur de lci qui a
publié en ce moment depuis la salle
d'audience quelques tweets nous
précisait que le 22 juin dernier le
ministère public avec avait requis des
peines d'avertissement trois mois
d'emprisonnement avec sursis contre les
trois prévenus poursuivis pour
harcèlement et six mois avec sursis
contre neuf autres prévenus renvoyés
pour harcèlement et menaces de mort
elle est en ce moment dans cette salle
où elle dit
à 9h03 que plusieurs prévenus sont
maintenant présents sur les bancs de la
salle d'audience que la salle est
maintenant rempli que les avocats des
prévenus et de la victime sont là il
était 9 heures 12 quand elle a publié
son message puisque nous n'avons pas
accès à la salle d'audience nous
attendons le jugement qui est rendue en
ce moment et nous le saurons dans
quelques minutes les prévenus dit elle
sont aussi présents le public et les
journalistes aussi et cette audience a
donc débuté il y à quelques minutes et
nous pourrons vous la faire vivre nous
faire vivre le rendu le jugement dans
quelques minutes
beaucoup d'internautes aussi s'interroge
sur les conditions de vie 2000 à qui je
le rappelle
à 18 ans et pour laquelle la sphère a
débuté quand elle avait 16 ans et demi
c'est une jeune lycéenne des scolytes
d'escaut déscolarisés pardon stefan
kovacs nous avons au raf là qui
s'interroge sur le chat youtube du
figaro pensez vous qu'un retour à la vie
normale est possible pour mille a en
tout cas je l'espère dit elle la pauvre
conclut-elle mais je l'espère aussi mais
pour l'instant quand on interroge sur
son avenir elle dit je ne le voit pas et
et puis son avocat explique nous fait
bien comprendre que qui va pouvoir lui
donner ne serait-ce qu'un stage si elle
est entouré de deux policiers si elle ne
peut pas sortir tranquillement souffre
avec une perruque habillée avec
plusieurs couches de vêtements comme
elle le décrit habillée comme une mouche
pour ne pas se faire remarquer elle qui
aime les couleurs vives et et les tenues
un peu exubérante
elle aimerait
enfin elle pensé à un moment faire de la
musique elle pensait aussi devenir
maquilleuse c'est un peu compliqué quand
on doit rester cloîtré dans sa chambre
l'école et la vie d'amy là
en ce moment s'interroge vincent m'a
l'avis de me lasser de rester donc chez
ses parents en isère et donc si on
s'étonne qu'elle soit tant sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'elle n'arrive pas à
s'en détacher il faut la comprendre
c'est parce que c'est sa seule fenêtre
un peu d'ouverture sur le monde pour
communiquer aussi avec ses amis
et donc on peut pas tellement quand même
lui reprocher d'aller de temps en temps
sur les réseaux sociaux
faire des vidéos pour un peu de la
musique se détendent ce qu'on sait à
demande vincent est ce qu'on en sait un
peu plus sur sur les menaces qu'elle a
reçus pendant le procès est
effectivement que se souvient de cette
image de millas n'intervenant pas
directement ne faisant pas part
directement de son opinion mais lisant
une menace qu'elle a reçu à la fin des
deux jours d'audience en juin dernier
qu'est ce qu'on sait de plus sur ce
message et sur les menaces autres
qu'elle aurait pu recevoir alors pendant
l'audience j'en ai vu quelques-uns
messages haineux alors pas des menaces
vraiment mais pour vous dire que ça a
continué pendant l'audience et le
deuxième jour donc le soir puisque ça
s'est terminé vers 22h30
elle est sortie et la face aux
journalistes elle a dit voilà je viens
de recevoir un nouveau message
et je vais vous lire ça a duré quatre
minutes
elle était très émue et c'était c'était
un déferlement d'injures extrêmement
vulgaire avec des appels au suicide des
menaces de mort de viol et elle a
terminé les larmes aux yeux en disant
ben apparemment il y en a qui n'ont pas
encore compris et c'est un peu ce qu'on
peut craindre
d'ailleurs j'ai fait un tweet avec en
parlant de ce message et du coup comme
milla
marc tweets et j'ai pu avoir un
échantillon de messages qu'elle recevait
et il y avait il y avait moins il y
avait des messages du style très bien
continuer à pleurer tu le mérites
mais il ya eu quand même de mémoire
quelqu'un qui lui disait donne moi ton
adresse la pression ne me fait pas peur
oui c'est extrêmement ambigu
malgré tout menaçant voilà pour vous
montrer que son avenir
voilà c'est en tout cas les menaces ne
s'arrête pas est ce qu elles
s'arrêteront avec les peines prononcées
est ce que ça va faire peur on verra
nous sommes en direct avec stefan kovacs
qui intervient et qui nous livre son
expertise sur le jugement qui devrait
nous parvenir dans quelques minutes sur
cette affaire mis là pour laquelle
treize prévenus attendent leur
condamnation ou pas sur ce qui leur est
reproché en l'occurrence des insultes
sur les réseaux sociaux et des menaces
de mort pour certains d'entre eux on
peut revenir peut-être stefan kovacs sur
les condamnations qu'il risque c'est
respect aux prévenus
qu'est ce qui a été requis contre eux
donc il a été requis jusqu'à six mois
avec sursis pour ceux qui ont proféré
des menaces de mort comme vous le disiez
notre consoeur aurélie sarrot le
rappeler je crois que c'est si ce qui
risque jusqu'à six mois
les autres
ne sont jugés que pour des menaces et ce
serait 3 mois et là puisque donc sur 13
y en a un qui n'a rien le procureur a
estimé qu'il y avait une ambiguïté
puisque il a tweeté faut la faire sauter
avec une photo de millas et l'a expliqué
à l'audience qu'il ne visait pas me la
met son compte twitter vous le voyez en
direct les images du tribunal de paris
ou en ce moment est rendu le jugement
concernant la ferme il a treize prévenus
doivent entendre leur jugement
aujourd'hui en tout cas ou directement
en présentant leur présence ou via leurs
avocats
notre consoeur aurélie sarrot de lci
précise dans les tweets qu'elle diffuse
en ce moment puisque lll et dans cette
salle d'audience que tous les prévenus
ne sont pas présents un certain nombre
d'entre eux sept sont présents en tout
cas et elle précise que cinq garçons et
deux filles se sont avancés à la barre
mickaël bourgain envers un bear pardon
qui est président du tribunal a annoncé
à 9h22 l'audience est ouverte
je vous invite à vous asseoir le
tribunal va rendre son délibéré
c'était à 9h22 il est 9h 29 donc les
choses sont en cours et on devrait avoir
le jugement dans quelques minutes
aurélie sarrot d'elle c'est ea précise
également que l'huissier informe que
plusieurs prévenus sont absents certains
sont représentés probablement par leurs
avocats
on continue à vous faire vivre ce
jugement qui doit être rendu dans
quelques minutes maintenant en direct
depuis le tribunal de paris nous sommes
sur le chat et figaro live lefigaro.fr
et sur youtube en parallèle également
vous êtes très nombreux à nous faire
part de vos commentaires et de vos
questions sur 1000 assure c'est treize
individus qui sont accusés d'avoir
proféré des menaces de mort entre autres
et de l'avoir harcelée
on le rappelle un peu tête stéphane
kovacs et les treize prévenus qui sont
aujourd'hui jugés non proféré de menaces
et de et ont ils sont accusés de
harcèlement que depuis novembre 2020
date à laquelle milla a de nouveau
publié un message qui critiquent l islam
il met rien aucun individu n'a été mis
en cause après sa première publication
qui avait déclenché la sphère en janvier
2020 non et c'est bien aussi ce que ce
qui pourrait montrer que ces individus à
intervenants donc en novembre savez
connaissait milla savez ce qui s'était
passé en janvier parce que quand on est
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est difficile
d'ignorer un peu l'histoire de millas et
donc ils ont beau avoir expliqué qu'il
n'était pas au courant qu'ils n'ont pas
receler qu'il n'avait pas vu qu'elle ait
d'autres messages etc
c'était un peu difficile a plaidé sa
l'ignorance de duke admis là vous êtes
un certain nombre sur les réseaux
sociaux en ce moment et sur les tchats
du figaro et de youtube à vous à
échanger entre vous en tout cas ne pas
être d'accord
par rapport à cette affaire sur en
particulier la question du droit au
blasphème est ce qu on peut rappeler
stefan kovacs ce qui est autorisé par la
loi ce qui ne l'est pas et pour ceux qui
s'interrogent pourquoi milla n'a pas été
condamné d'une manière ou d'une autre
par rapport aux propos qu'elle a tenus
par deux fois en janvier 2020 et en
novembre 2020
parce que milla n'a fait que critiquer
une religion et en france s'est permis
ça s'appelle le blasphème tout
simplement
donc en france on peut critiquer mon
avis valoir t atteinte à des personnes
n'est pas critiquer ou insulter des
individus donc par rapport aux propos
même extrêmement gros cible a peut être
pu tenir par deux fois publiquement rien
ne pas mettre le vocabulaire
d'adolescentes son âge je découvre au
fur et à mesure un vos messages sur les
réseaux sociaux et je vois que
effectivement vous échangé beaucoup
d'entre vous
en particulier sur le figaro.fr il ya
aussi pas mal de questions sur la
responsabilité des réseaux sociaux qui
ne sont pas mises en cause
en tout cas pour l'instant dans cette
affaire ce qu'il est question qu'à terme
il est mise en cause de twitter ou de en
tout cas instagram aux tic toc qui sont
eux les les supports sur lesquels millas
est exprimée et puis aussi les supports
par lesquels les c'est ce qui est du
nombre est estimé par beaucoup d'avocats
déjà c'est très compliqué de faire
supprimer un message dès lors qu'on on
isole un message malveillant twitter
notamment qu opère très difficilement
mais bon pour la france c'est niet qu'un
voeu pieux ou à peut-être voir les
images de l'arrivée de millas au
tribunal avec son avocat si on peut les
rejouer pour que vous les voyez ils sont
passés très rapidement un peu avant 9
heures devant les caméras de télévision
ils sont entrés dans cette salle
d'audience où il dit sont en ce moment
milla masquer tout comme son entourage
et son avocat s'est présenté donc peu
avant 9 heures voilà on revoit ses
images peut-être voilà donc ça c'était
peu avant 9 heures l'arrivée de millas
donc il ne s'est pas exprimée avant son
entrée dans cette salle d'audience on le
voit son avocat et suivait derrière elle
donc sa protection policière qui
l'accompagnent en permanence depuis des
mois maintenant
et puis il ya aussi la femme protection
policière pour maître malka et une
protection policière pour son avocat
maître malka qui est l'avocat des
chalets charlie hebdo aussi qui est
également l'avocat de charlie hebdo
voilà vous venez de voir ces images donc
de l'arrivée de 2000 ha au tribunal de
paris elle a précédé son arrivée a
précédé celle d'un certain nombre de
deux prévenus en l'occurrence treize
prévenus son attente de leur jugement
aujourd'hui dans cette affaire ils sont
accusés d'avoir proféré des menaces de
mort pour certains d'entre eux en
novembre 2020 suite à une publication
qui critiquer l'islam 2000 assure sur
tik tok
voilà je vais citer de nouveau notre
consoeur aurélie sarrot qui twitte en ce
moment depuis la salle d'audience où
elle est présente journalistes sur lci
elle dit le président michael humbert
dit le réseau social c'est la rue quand
vous croisez quelqu'un dans la rue on
s'interdirait d'insulter quelqu'un de le
menacer de se moquer ce que vous ne
faites pas dans la rue ne le fait pas
sur les réseaux sociaux donc c'est le
président du tribunal qui s'adresse en
ce moment à au prévenu qui se sont
présentés ce matin pour attendre leur
jugement ils sont au nombre de sept sur
les 13 5 garçons et deux filles
alors je vois qu'il ya des choses qui
sont en train d'arriver
je ne sais pas comment l'interpréter
donc aurélie sarrot nous dit michael
humbert dis donc président du tribunal
la peine de privation des droits
d'éligibilité pour une durée d'un an ça
c'est le seul message que j'ai pour
l'instant
est-ce qu'il s'agirait d'une des
premières condamnations ou en tout cas
des premiers propos en rapport avec une
possible condamnation
on verra dans quelques minutes quand on
aura plus d'infos par rapport à ces
éléments là ce qu'on peut dire puisque
vous parliez de du président c'est que
tout au long de ces deux jours
d'audience il s'est montré très
pédagogue il a essayé il a dit au moins
que cette audience servent à vous faire
comprendre certaines choses a posé les
limites de la liberté d'expression de ce
qu'on peut faire ou de ce qu'on ne peut
pas faire sur les réseaux sociaux par
exemple puis quand il là il a vu que
tous les prévenus ou presque disait j'ai
pas réfléchi
j'avais pas pensé j'ai pas compris
cetera il a dit est ce que on est moins
responsable d'une chose quand on l'a
fait sans réfléchir il a essayé de nous
pousser justement à réfléchir de leur
faire comprendre il a essayé aussi
d'expliquer comment ont présenté ses
excuses à millas pour pour l'un d'entre
eux l'un des prévenus qu'ils voulaient
présenter ses excuses
et puis ben il a aussi c'était c'était
le même c'était enzo qui
qui avait dit alors enzo a répondu à un
internaute qui disait entre oui la
différence entre mila et allah sait que
milla on a la preuve qu'elle existe et
enzo a écrit plus pour longtemps et à la
barre il a dit qu'en fait c'était parce
qu'il s'inquiétait pour milla est donc
le président ne s'est pas démontée a dit
ah oui alors si tout à l'heure le
procureur vous dit enzo vous êtes libre
et moi je rajoute plus pour longtemps
vous allez penser à le président
s'inquiète pour moi et donc la enzo je
crois a compris que ce qu'il avait écrit
était était grave surtout que l'autre
message qu'il envoyait c'est quand même
tu mérites de te faire égorger salle
grosse [ __ ]
est-ce que vous avez été frappé
justement par une certaine forme
d'immaturité de ses treize prévenus
encore une fois je le rappelle est
qu'ils sont accusés d'avoir proféré des
menaces de mort pour certains d'entre
eux à l'encontre de me la jeune lycéenne
de 18 ans tout à fait il y a aussi un ce
qui est impressionnant c'est le
contraste parfois entre l'horreur des
messages que je vais t'égorger de la
série avec mon plus beau couteaux etc et
est d'une maturité de certains propos
comme comme par exemple un mehdi qui lui
a adressé à mes amis là je me lasse ce
message calage famas 9 mm uzi et p38 les
armes sont payantes mais les rafale sont
gratuites
alors ça en fait ce sont des paroles
d'une chanson c'est la seule que je
connais ce qu'il a dit à la barre mais
après il lui twittos si tu es trop moche
ou mots jetés à qu'elle est moche et le
lendemain avec 24 heures de maturité en
plus comme a fait remarquer le président
il invite ses amis à voter entre une
photo de millas et une photo d'une
tortue voilà donc vous voyez
l'immaturité de certains profils et
s'est révélé de nouveau à la lors de ces
deux jours de procès oui ce qu'on peut
dire aussi ce qui m'a frappé c'est que
ben comment comment ils s'informent
principalement par les réseaux sociaux
et lorraine par exemple
raconte que oui elle a bien entendu de
parler de ça mais elle pâtit mais bon on
n'en sait pas plus que ça et puis on
leur dont l'art a demandé à plusieurs
d'entre eux de quoi ils débattaient en
famille pendant les repas est-ce qu'on
parlait de religion chez eux et c'est
aux politiques non de foot
ont-ils répondu certains en tout cas
donc on voit là des profils de jeunes
gens un petit peu bas seuls devant leur
ordinateur déjà puisqu'on n'est pas dans
le confinement
c'est un argument d'ailleurs qui a été
mis en avant par leurs propres avocats
mais voilà ils sont seuls ils n'ont ils
sont fatigués ils sont déprimés ils
n'ont pas de cours en présentiel il
d'ailleurs ils n'ont comme comme tous
les élus jeunes étudiants d'ailleurs ils
n'ont même pas pu encore se faire des
amis à l'université puisqu'ils ont
peut-être quelques heures de course et
tout donc pour certains ils sont arrivés
dans des villes qu'ils ne connaissent
pas ou ils ne connaissent personne et
ils sont enfermés dans leur petite
chambre d'étudiant et et voilà comme
certains ont dit bah j'ai pété les
plombs j'ai pas supporté qu'elle
critique ma religion ou qu'elle critique
la religion de mon meilleur ami ou de
mon père qui s'est converti ou je ne
sais quoi et c'est comme ça que ben
qu'ils ont envoyé ces messages terrible
ils ont envoyé ces messages terrible it
vous stefan kovacs et c'est pour cela
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui au tribunal de
paris et qu'ils attendent donc leur
jugement ses treize prévenus donc accusé
d'avoir proféré des menaces de mort et
d'avoir harcelé mis là je le rappelle
milla qui avait critiqué l'islam sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur instagram en
janvier 2020 et qui a donc subi on va
dire harcèlement massifs et des menaces
de mort puisqu'on parle de plus de cent
mille messages publiés sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur ses cent mille messages
seuls treize individus aujourd'hui
attendent leur jugement
d'autres individus sont en attente d'un
procès de ce que vous disiez stefan
kovacs mais il
pour l'instant oui on a la possibilité
d'un procès en ce qui les concerne
puisqu'ils sont aux mineurs ou basés à
l'étranger en tout cas aujourd'hui et
depuis plusieurs mois 1000 à 18 ans est
accompagné au quotidien par une
protection policière elle vit cloîtrée
on va dire chez ses parents dans l'isère
si je ne me trompe pas système d sur le
chat figaro live sur youtube nous
demandent pourquoi
mylan est elle plus en sécurité dans
aucun lycée de france
pourquoi parce que justement elle est
menacée de mort
alors vous me direz peut-être mais ces
jeunes gens ils sont pas dangereux
d'ailleurs l'avocat de me la mettre mal
qu'a l'a bien dit ce sont vos enfants
même at il dit donc ce sont des jeunes
certes qui ne sont qui ne ne serait pas
passé à l'acte ils ont d'ailleurs dit à
la barre s'il avait croisé milla dans la
rue il était juste très énervé et ça
leur a fait du bien d'écrire sa honte il
dit pour la plupart mais on l'a vu dans
la sphère samuel pâtit
les le fait d'écrire des menaces sur des
réseaux sociaux
ça peut peut-être incité certains
profils perturber ou disons radicaux à
passer à l'acte et donc elle est en
danger donc à l'étang du genre oui donc
on parlait des établissements elle a
donc été dans un établissement géré par
l'armée qui elle-même l'armée donc elle
a été renvoyé cet établissement parce
qu' on ne pouvait plus assurer sa
sécurité et les autres les autres jeunes
étaient ceux considérés aussi en danger
merci de nous suivre en direct nous
sommes et vous venez de l'entendre en
compagnie de stéphane kovacs grand
reporter au service société du figaro
qui répond à toutes vos questions et vos
commentaires sur le chat du figaro
figaro.fr figaro live et sur youtube le
comte figaro live de alors on voit les
images dit tribunal de paris en ce
moment nous sommes postés via l' afp
devant la porte de cette salle
d'audience qui s'est refermée peu après
9 heures après y avoir laissé entrer
millar
et son avocat qui sont arrivés dans les
premiers à peu avant 9 heures suivie par
un certain nombre de prévenus parmi les
treize qui attendent leur jugement
aujourd'hui accompagné également de
leurs avocats respectifs puisqu'on a pu
voir l'avocat juan branco qui est
l'avocate du prévenu
jordan dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
stefan kovacs
est ce qu'on peut dire quelques mots sur
le profil type si un profil type parmi
ses harceleurs ou bien pas du tout leur
profil au contraire et leur diversité
montre qu'il n'ya pas harceleur type ou
une harceleuse puisqu'il ya même des
femmes parmi les marcheurs s'étaient
réveillés à trois jeunes femmes
trois étudiantes
je dirais pas enfin iso iso
ils ont des points communs ils ont ils
ont tous réagi ont ils dit choqué enfin
au nom de leur religion même s'il
n'était pas de religion musulmane
ils peuvent être athée mais avoir un
membre de leur famille ou des amis
proches qui sont musulmans et donc être
choqué parce que ils disent ils ont
considéré que c'était racistes ce que
disait milla mais il est bon ce qui le
point commun aussi c'est leur jeunesse
le fait que donc ils sont pour la
plupart étudiants le fait que ben may
qu'ils sont qu'ils sont seuls devant
leurs écrans pendant une longue période
à ce moment là je vous interromps stefan
kovacs parce que en lisant les messages
diffusés sur twitter par un autre
concert aurélie sarrot de lci
je vois que le président s'est exprimé
de nouveau il a face à lui sept prévenus
sur les treize cinq hommes deux femmes
et il vient de dire que le tribunal a
rejeté les demandes de non inscription
au casier
les personnes n'ont pas exprimé de
repentir et il y à un risque de récidive
qu'est ce que cela veut dire il avait
demandé à ce qu'ils aient non
inscription de leur condamnation au
casier c'est ça dont ils ont tous
évidemment demandé la relaxe et mais au
cas où etc
il y aurait une peine leur avocat
demandait la non inscription en arguant
du fait que intel s'était inscrit à une
formation par exemple de d'infirmiers
souviens bien ou enfin dont des
professions où il fallait avoir un cas
si je veux dire judiciaire vierge et
donc là vous nous apprenez que ça a été
refusé donc pour tous
aucun horace a priori de ce que je lis
il ajoute par ailleurs la médiatisation
2000 à travers les vidéos les polémiques
l'explosion des messages bienveillants
aux malveillants
le tribunal a considéré que pour la
plupart des prévenus devant lui
l'infraction de harcèlement et est
caractérisée il a également considéré
que l'infraction de menaces de mort et
est considérée pour la plupart d'entre
eux on est toujours sur les propos
restitué 1 par notre consoeur aurélie
sarrot de lci sur twitter michael
humbert président du tribunal a dit par
ailleurs que le tribunal considère qu'il
s'agit d'une véritable entreprise de
harcèlement et il ajoute également
d'après aurait aurélie sarrot le
tribunal a fait le choix de ne pas
retenir la qualification avec la peine
la plus élevée quand il y avait les deux
infractions à l'exception d'une prévenue
donc ça c'est un peu technique est
qu'elle moi alors j'ai pas de précision
sur le nom de la prévenue et comme je
vous le disais donc le tribunal a rejeté
les demandes de non-inscription au
casier les personnes n'ont pas exprimé
de repentir et il ya un risque de
récidive selon le président du guyana on
le disait tout à l'heure qui a exprimé
ses regrets et qui a demandé pardon à
millas c'est enzo celui de ton paraît
tout à l'heure qui avait répondu plus
pour longtemps à quelqu'un qui disait
entre mina et
la halle a dû lancer quand on sait que
milan elle existe et il avait aussi
écrit tu mérites de te faire égorger
salle grosse [ __ ] mais j'ai la suite
pardon stefan kovacs et vous coupez
michael lambert le président du tribunal
donc nous dit qu'il condamne les onze
prévenus à des peines de quatre à six
mois d'emprisonnement avec sursis
pierre entre autres qui avait écrit il
faut la faire sauter et relax et ça vous
l'aviez précisé vers saint-louis puisque
le procureur avait demandé la relaxe
pour pierre puisque c'est ambigu son
message pour la faire sauter le
président a dit également toujours selon
aurélie sarrot de lci sur twitter le
tribunal a annulé la garde à vue de
lorraine j'aimais ça n'annule pas ni la
saisine ni ce qui s'est dit avant la
garde à vue ils annulent deux autres
gardes à vue au motif que celles-ci ont
été notifiés tardivement je découvre en
même temps que je suis avec vous les
messages plusieurs prévenus sont
condamnés à verser à 1000 à 1500 euros
chacun à raison de ses souffrances
endurées et 1000 euros chacun pour les
frais d'avocat alors que l'on voit en ce
moment juan branco l'avocat d'un des
prévenus en l'occurrence jordan qui
s'exprime en ce moment depuis le
tribunal de paris de condamner mais qui
ont des peines lourdes mais pour le
principe
parce qu'on considère qu'il ya des
enjeux de droits essentiels dans le
cadre de cette affaire dans le cadre de
la loi schiappa qui était adoptée en
2018 et que l'extrême violence qui
consiste à arrêter aléatoirement très
citoyen
au petit matin sans raison particulière
du fait d'un mouvement hamas auquel ils
n'ont contribué que marginalement
devrait inquiéter l'ensemble des
français merci
net mettre votre nom
vous venez d'entendre l'intervention
très rapide de l'un des avocats des
treize prévenus
juan branco m branco qui vient de
s'exprimer très rapidement et brièvement
face aux caméras de télévision juste au
sortir de cette salle d'audience où
vient d'être rendu le jugement
concernant ses treize prévenus accusés
de harcèlement et de et de menaces de
mort à l'encontre de 1000 ha dont on
attend la sortie de cette salle
d'audience en présence de son avocat
peut-être interviendra-t-elle face aux
caméras les prévenus dont viennent
d'entendre leur jugement je voulais dit
par l'intermédiaire de notre consoeur
aurélie sarrot de lci sur twitter le
président du tribunal a annoncé au
prévenu qui les considère responsable
des dommages causés à millas et qui
verseraient évidemment qui leur
verserait évidemment des dommages et
intérêts plusieurs prévenus sont
condamnés à verser à 1000 à 1500 euros
chacun en raison de ses souffrances
endurées et 1000 euros chacun pour les
frais d'avocat le tribunal condamne onze
prévenus à des peines de quatre à six
mois d'emprisonnement avec sursis et
pierre l'un des prévenus des treize
prévenus qui avaient écrit il faut la
faire sauter et relaxer et ça stéphane
kovacs vous nous aviez précisé que
c'était le seul des treize prévenus
qu'ils pouvaient bénéficier en
définitive d'une relaxe
allez-y je vous en prie je compte bien
ça fait 11 vous me parlez de construire
je n'ai pas d'information supplémentaire
pour l'instant de ce qui s'est dit
précisément dans cette salle d'audience
par l'intermédiaire de son président on
devrait en savoir plus dans quelques
minutes
[Musique]
je dois encore une fois les adages la
dernière c'était là une prévenue vous
avez cités et weeds et des suspensions
de des suppressions de garde à vue on
s'était pas la suppression de garde à
vue c'était donc il y en avait 11 qui
étaient condamnées et l'unil avait
retenu je ne sais plus quoi
alors attendez que je retrouve un peu
mes tweets
le président du tribunal en tout cas a
précisé michael humbert au prévenu vous
avez dix jours pour faire appel de notre
décision effectivement les prévenus ont
le droit de faire appel s'il estime que
cette peine qui ont été prononcées ne
leur conviennent pas bien sûr comme tous
les prévenus
et qu'est ce qu'ils disent qu'est-ce qui
se passerait dans ces cas là un nouveau
procès aurait lieu
de nouveau dans quelques mois et à
propos de procès ça n'est pas le seul
qui pourrait avoir lieu
d'autres sont à venir dont ne veut pas
venir puisque l'en quête continue
puisque malheureusement les messages de
haine aussi se poursuivre et le
procureur l'a bien dit c'est c'est une
enquête au long cours et il y aura
d'autres
d'autres procès comme celui là je vous
lis encore une fois un tweet d'aurélie
sarraut notre consoeur d'elle c'est y
qui se trouvait dans cette salle
d'audience dont on voit sortir quelques
quelques avocats de nouveau et peut-être
des prévenus
une partie des familles michael humbert
le président du tribunal a exprimé face
au prévenu ses propos chacun a le droit
d'avoir un avis un commentaire sur notre
décision mais confondre ce sentiment
avec un jugement cet autre chose pour
arriver à ce jugement le tribunal a lu
quatre mille huit cents pages et avec
une 26 heures de débats nous sommes
toujours en direct sur figaro live vous
êtes vous même avec nous via le chat
filière alive sur lefigaro.fr et sur
youtube nous sommes vous le voyez en
direct depuis le tribunal de paris où le
jugement a été rendu sur la ferme il a
et qui mettait en cause très individus
femmes et hommes qui était accusé
d'avoir harcelé milla sur les réseaux
sociaux les réseaux sociaux et d'avoir
proféré des menaces de mort on voit
encore quelques personnes sortir on
aimerait savoir si maître malka richard
malka l'avocat de 2000 à s'exprimera est
elle même est ce qu elle prendra la
parole face aux caméras dans quelques
minutes on a pu entendre m branco juan
branco qui est l'avocat d'un des treize
prévenus qui s'est exprimé il ya
quelques minutes maintenant en direct
je laisse vivre quelques minutes ces
images on voit toujours sortir de cette
salle d'audience des personnes qui sont
des avocats des peut-être des prévenus
eux mêmes ou une partie de leur
entourage
on disait au début de ce direct que
c'est un procès inédit en quoi c'était
fameux kovacs et procès un caractère
inédit certains internautes passent
parler d'un procès historique on est ce
qu'on peut considérer également que
c'est un pot c'est historique
alors c'est un procès inédit d'abord
parce que c'est c'est l'un des premiers
procès après une enquête du pôle
national de lutte contre la haine en
ligne qui a été créé il ya quelques mois
et puis la fraction de cyber-harcèlement
elle même a été créée par une loi de
et donc je vous rappelle l'infraction du
cyberharcèlement elle peut être
constitué dès lors que plusieurs
personnes s'en prennent à une même
victime
même s'ils ne font dès lors qu'il savait
que leurs propos ou comportements
caractérise une répétition même s'ils
n'ont pas agi de manière concertée
je vais vous faire part d'un certain
nombre de commentaires que nous recevons
en ce moment sur le chat du figaro.fr en
particulier les commentaires les
réflexions d'un internaute qui s'appelle
christian les ont tous un conte salut
merci à lui
la ferme il a dévoile un problème de
notre temps dit-il le harcèlement des
réseaux et des anonymes nous internautes
du figaro avons tous été harcelés ou
insulter pour nos opinions de la vérité
dit-il
même si nous reconnaissons posté sur un
réseau libre et populaire cn pour nos
opinions de l'actualité ne doivent pas
être publié l'opinion n'est de la
synthèse de l'actualité peut être vérité
admin il devrait s'exprimer mais je
voulais tout simplement commencer par
bernard six manches remercier mes
parents pour la partie ils ont eu
jusqu'à présent parce que ça fait 18
mois que ça leur est tombée dessus qui
vivent le même le même calvaire que man
alors qu'ils ont rien demandé je
remercie mon avocat pour sa persévérance
pour tout ce qu'il a fait jusqu'à
présent et encore à l'avenir qui est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement admirable je
remercie les forces de l'ordre pour
assurer aussi bien ma protection
les personnes qui ont aidé à constituer
le dossier je remercie les féministes
qui m'ont soutenu j'ai de la peine pour
les autres car je ne les considère tout
simplement pas comme des féministes les
associés les associations antiracistes
qui ont eu le courage de me soutenir
quant aux autres que je considère qu'ils
ne luttent pas contre le racisme et m
je m'attendais à bien pire et maintenant
on a gagné et on gagnerait encore parce
que ce que je veux c'est que tous
ensemble on n'arrête jamais baissé les
bras qu'on continue de se battre
ce que je veux c'est que les personnes
qui seraient considérés comme des
pestiférés à qui on interdirait les
réseaux sociaux ce soit ceux qui
harcèlent qui prive de la liberté des
gens ce qui menace de mort ce qui incite
au suicide et je veux plus jamais qu'on
fasse culpabiliser les victimes
et comme je le dis dans mon livre force
à nous
c'est le protéger
vous venez de l'entendre milla cette
jeune lycéenne de 18 ans qui s'est
présenté au tribunal de paris ce matin à
9 heures pour entendre le jugement
concernant 13 prévenus accusés de
harcèlement et de menaces de mort
proférées à son encontre en novembre
2020 suite à une critique de l'islam
qu'elle avait publiées sur tik tok une
seconde critique qui faisait suite à
celle qu'elle avait publié en janvier
2020 c'est prévenus eux mêmes ou
représentés par leurs avocats étaient
eux mêmes au tribunal de paris ce matin
le jugement a été rendu on vient
d'entendre milla qui a réagi à ce
jugement au sortir de cette salle
d'audience elle s'est exprimée en
remerciant ses avocats les forces de
l'ordre qui assure sa protection
policière au quotidien elle a précisé
également qu'elle remerciait les
féministes qui l'ont soutenu mais pas
les autres et également qu'elle
remerciait les associations antiracistes
qui l'ont soutenu je m'attendais à bien
pire concernant ce jugement at elle dit
mais on a gagné je veux qu'on continue à
se battre at elle précisé je ne veux
plus jamais qu'on fasse culpabiliser les
victimes at elle dit entre autres une
réaction de votre part stefan kovacs
jaune journaliste grand reporter au
service société du biéreau qu'on
remercie parce que vous avez été avec
nous depuis une heure et demie pour
commenter ce jugement cet évènement
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de cette
réaction de cette jeune femme
et oui on la sent très ému
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'on n'a pas dit
avancé que puisqu'on plusieurs
internautes m'ont demandé pourquoi elle
s'arrête pas d'aller sur les réseaux
sociaux et caetera et elle a dit aussi
pourquoi ce serait aux victimes de
s'arrêter là les réseaux sociaux et moi
je veux que ce soit c'est ses harceleurs
qu'on condamne elle elle l'avait dit
aussi lors de l'audience on veut
m'interdire de parler d'islam il
faudrait que je me fasse oublier et que
je me soumettent non je me soumettrai
pas et donc on voit qu'elle est toujours
dans cet état des objets elle remercie
ceux qui l'ont soutenu et elle voit pas
pourquoi elle s'arrêterait et d'aller
sourire de sociaux et de parler d'islam
si c'est la même envie on l'a senti et
mieux cette jeune femme qui s'exprime et
donc il ya quelques minutes en direct
face aux caméras de télévision c'est une
émotion qu'elle avait également à la fin
de son procès du pape à la fin du procès
pardon des treize prévenus en juin
dernier exactement puisque elle nous a
lu un très long message de quatre
minutes d'un qu'elle venait de recevoir
qui était abominable et elle disait ben
j'ai l'impression que ça va jamais
s'arrêter que certains n'ont pas compris
en tout cas milla s'est exprimé en
disant je m'attendais à bien pire mais
on a gagné donc pour rappel ce jugement
à l'encontre de treize prévenus a été
rendu aux personnes ont été condamnées à
des peines de quatre à six mois de
prison avec sursis treize prévenus
étaient jugés à paris donc pour avoir
participé au harcèlement en ligne de
l'adolescente milla après sa vidéo
polémique sur l'islam publié en novembre
je vous lis la dépêche qui est parvenu
et qui dit que le tribunal de paris a
prononcé des peines allant de quatre à
six mois de prison avec sursis contre
onze personnes reconnues coupables
d'avoir participé au harcèlement en
ligne de l'adolescente milla et cetera
vous précise également qu'un non-lieu a
également été prononcée pour vice de
procédure et un seul détresse prévenu a
été relaxé sur les 11 personnes
reconnues coupables l'une a été condamné
pour menaces de mort à cause d'un mail
particulièrement explicites envoyé à la
plaignante quand les dix autres qui
n'avait envoyé qu'un seul message sur
twitter l'ont été pour harcèlement voilà
notre direct s'achève merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi sur fille lefigaro.fr
figaro live et d'avoir commenté et poser
vos questions sur youtube également
merci beaucoup
stefan kovacs d'avoir été en direct avec
nous et d'avoir répondu aux internautes
et à nos questions sur cette affaire et
ce jugement qui a été rendu au tribunal
de paris
aujourd'hui je rappelle que vous êtes
grand reporter au service société du
figaro et qu'on peut retrouver tous vos
papiers sur lefigaro.fr et dans les
pages du figaro papier
merci encore à très vite sur figaro live